notre invité politique ce matin c'est
eric woerth bonjour bonjour si beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes député de
l'oise président de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale et on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern est bonjour stéphane
giuranne stéphane qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france
on va parler évidemment longtemps de
l'allocution d'emmanuel macro eric
woerth d'abord avant de rentrer dans le
détail des mesures est ce que ces
discours que vous attendiez ce qu'il a
trouvé le bon ton hier soir le chef de
l'état compte tenu du contexte
écoutez je je je pense que les décisions
qu'il a prises ou qu'il a annoncé hier
sur les bonnes décisions
je pense qu'elle arrive tardivement mais
il ya un moment donné il faut qu'ils
aient de l'autorité qui s'exerce
il faut remettre un peu d'ordre on peut
pas vivre des vagues comme ça d'épidémie
sans s'en ressent sans prévoir les
choses et là on les a prévu à la fois on
est capable de les prévoir ce n'est pas
le cas de la première évidemment on est
capable de les prévoir et d'anticiper
puis deuxième point on a le remède c'est
à dire le vaccin est les vaccins sont
sûrs et les vaccins sont efficaces c'est
un débat de pays riches que nous avons
aujourd'hui sur sur le sur le vaccin
je suis pas sûr qu'en afrique qu'en inde
il est ce type de débat alors qu' il ya
des milliers de morts chaque jour dans c
dans ces pays là donc ce débat là il
doit être traité
évidemment dans le respect des libertés
publiques qui peut penser le contraire
en france mais la liberté publique c'est
la liberté des autres aussi des autres
et pas uniquement votre propre liberté
mais à ce contrat du coup est ce que le
chef de l'état avait pas intérêt à
imposer la vaccination obligatoire pour
tous où plus de 12 ans je pense qu'il
faut procéder par étapes et il faut
tenter d'essayer de convaincre nos
concitoyens qui ne sont pas convaincus
qu'il faut se faire vacciner
donc je pense qu'il a il a raison
il à dire qu'il ouvre la keynote
vaccination pour tous que d'abord il
mise sur l âge du personnel soignant les
personnels au contact du du public
évidemment comment peut-on être
soignants aujourd'hui et ne pas être
vaccinés c'est impossible à un moment
donné il faut choisir
je sais bien que ça pose plein de
problèmes ça pose des problèmes
d'organisation des hôpitaux il ya des
soignants sans doute qu'ils partiront
bon bah ce sera leur choix et c'est
compliqué pour faire fonctionner les
hôpitaux quand on voit quand on voit la
modification des règles du pass
sanitaire de techniquement très
concrètement des gens qui sont pas
vaccinés n'auront plus accès à aucune
aucune vie sociale mais ça veut dire que
ceux qui sont vaccinées on aura accès à
toute la vie sociale
c'est plutôt au dessus plutôt le
contraire c'est pas ce n'est pas une
façon finalement d'imposer la
vaccination de la rendre obligatoire
sans le dire ça veut dire qu'on incite
fortement
enfin le principe c'est quand même
d'inciter c'est comme dans la fiscalité
vous inciter les gens baisser les impôts
et vous m baisser les impôts vous
inciter à faire telle ou telle chose
dans la vie est pleine d'incitation
quand il reconnaît les dissuasions enfin
la dissuasion nucléaire ça veut dire
qu'à un moment donné on se sert pas de
là et puis et puis on essaye de faire en
sorte de douane appliqués en sorte que
ça se traduise par de par la paix et
c'est la même chose sûre je crois qu'il
faut de l'autorité
on peut pas nous nous le leur on est un
parti dans lesquels on prône l'autorité
c'est une vision très gaulliste des
choses beaucoup de démocraties beaucoup
de liberté beaucoup d'autorité bon alors
on est dans un cas où l'autorité doit
doit jouer un projet accepté que la
moitié de la population soit pas
aujourd'hui vaccinés ou en passe de la
d7 autorités qui va la faire appliquer
parce que de luttes concrètement les
règles comment ça se passe on fait
sceller les patrons de cafés et de
restaurants cinémas les chacun sur leur
rôle et à l'entrée les superficies
contrôle élevé voire un projet de base
projet de loi à partir du 21 à
l'assemblée ça vous paraît elle quelques
jours après au sénat c'est compliqué
mais c'est plus compliqué que le laisser
faire laisser aller si vous laissez
faire vous laisser aller tout le monde
on revient à la vie d'avant et puis ont
subi une quatrième bague et puis à un
moment donné on se dit mais c'est
horrible il ya des milliers de morts par
jour et à ce moment-là referme touvre et
vous voulez quoi vous croyez que c'est
facile mais non c'est pas facile
moi je préfère un restaurant ouvert qui
était ce qu'il y a
une un contrôle de passes annie terre ou
de vaccination si c'est simple
évidemment un contrôle et je me mets
évidemment la place de ceux qui devront
exercer dans leur propre établissement
le contrôle mais c'est pour éviter la la
fermeture
évidemment que c'est pas facile
évidemment que c'est pas simple pour les
soignants par exemple il faudra bien le
vérifier pour un sou aignan qui n'aura
pas décidé personnellement c'est sa
propre décision de ne pas se faire
vacciner et donc in fine et de mettre en
danger la vie des autres c'est ça la
question ne pourra pas exercer sa
profession colisée vers ans quand il dit
hier c'est au 15 septembre vous êtes
soignants vous n'êtes pas vacciné vous
ne pourrez plus travailler vous deviez
prépayés il a eu raison
oui il faut annoncer les choses ont fait
un départ entre entre gamins dans une
école maternelle on est entre adultes
dans un pays adultes dans un pays mature
sur le plan des libertés publiques et à
un moment donné il faut choisir la
liberté des autres c'est aussi d'avoir
en face de vous quelqu'un dans un train
qui est vaccinée ou qu'il ya impasse
sanitaires equihen passani terre qui est
payant évidemment partir du moment où il
n'a pas été prescrit par un par un par
un médecin il faut bien faire la
différence entre personnes vaccinées les
personnes qui ne le sont pas
les personnes qui ne le sont pas
représentés dans g pour la pour les
autres est possible et d'être est
étonnamment parce que je pense que
beaucoup de ces personnes appellent à la
solidarité disent qu'il faut faire plus
pour les pays pauvres se se sont plaints
de 2,2 de compassion pour pour les
balades et en même temps ils sont pas
vaccinés et tu as un problème quand on
lit d'ailleurs dans la presse dans vos
journaux dont vous allez interroger des
personnes qui disent moi je me fais pas
vacciner parce que je sais pas je pense
je sais pas ce qu'il va rentrer dans mon
corps tous enfin des d'abord ils sont
déjà vaccinés en général et puis ce
vaccin ne présente les vaccins ne
présente aucun problème fondamentaux
donc je veux dire ça veut dire que c'est
une extraordinaire un exam égoïsme total
on est dans l'égoïsme totale démocratie
ce pas l'égoïsme total on vit
avec les autres on peut pas faire courir
des risques aux autres mais à un moment
donné ça deviendra pénale le choix niant
qui est est infecté et qui infecte
quelqu'un d un moment donné les familles
se retourneront contre ces soignants et
la justice qui est pas tendre en angola
au delà d'elle même qui est pas tendre
eh bien elle elle passera donc c'est
aussi cela propre protection des uns et
des autres et puis d un dernier point il
ya plein de pays qui aujourd'hui n'ont
pas accès au vaccin il ya 2 % de
l'afrique qui tu as eu accès à un moment
donné sur une dose ou deux doses au
vaccin
et c'est vrai pour les c'est vrai pour
l'inde enfin il ya plein de pays la
major la majorité de l'humanité n'a pas
accès la majorité de l'humanité n'a pas
accès au vaccin
si nous voulons nous les pays dits
riches si nous voulons aider ces pays il
faut aider l'humanité d'une manière
générale on peut pas parler d'elle delà
de la planète sans arrêt sur le plan
écologique et pas parler de la planète
sur le plan humain cette planète sur le
plan humain elle a besoin d' aide et si
nous voulons aider puissamment nous les
pays du nord ont les pays de l'ouest
très puissant si nous voulons aider tous
ces pays à surmonter 7,7
cette pandémie il faut évidemment se
dégager du temps il faut que nous soient
dégagées évidemment deux sets de 7
pendant un dernier mot sur cette
facilité l'économie justement mais un
dernier mot sur la clé center on se
souvient que lors des débats
parlementaires sur le passe à lithaire
la question de l'appliquer aux actes de
la vie quotidienne c'est à dire les bars
les restaurants ça avait été une sorte
de ligne rouge ça n'avait d'ailleurs pas
été votée est-ce que là vous dites il a
raison il faut la petite j'en ai parlé
dès le mois de mai pas de cette année
l'année d'avant et donc le jeu je suis
assez je pense que il faut limiter
l'accès à tout
toutes personnes non vaccinées ne ne
peut pas avoir accès aux lieux où
contre les autres dans des circonstances
où les gestes barrières tombent parce
qu'il ya des risques d'infection et
quand il ya des variantes puis blanc la
roue laisse prospérer les variantes
groupe où vous transmettez la maladie et
puis vous la faites vous prospérer les
vous fait prospérer les variants et ses
variantes sont extrêmement semble-t-il
ce variant delta celui dont on parle
aujourd'hui est extrêmement contagieux
il est extrêmement dangereux
les vaccins fonctionne sur ce valeur moi
je ne fais que dire ce que disent elles
à la majorité des experts dans ce
domaine donc il faut évidemment faut
évidemment faire une différence très
grosse différence entre les gens qui
sont vaccinées quand accepté de se
protéger et de protéger les autres et
ceux qui n'acceptent pas de se protéger
de protéger les autres
il faut qu'ils aient des différences
fondamentales on peut pas avoir accès
aux mêmes libertés publiques on ne peut
pas avoir accès aux autres de la même
façon c'est moi ce que je dis là j'ai
l'impression de faire de la nommer
clairement assumé cette partie pour le
vote l'autre partie de l'allocution
présidentielle
hier la priorité de sortie de crise sera
la même que depuis le début du
quinquennat 10 mm macro le travail et le
mérite ça vous rappelle pas quelqu'un
même si si ça me rappelle ça me rappelle
des des campagnes que nous avons déjà
mais évidemment la valeur travail il est
au coeur de notre engagement
tant mieux si un peu de sarkozy on nous
touche c'est une bonne chose finalement
il a donc je pense je pense que la
france sait pas comment le dire parce
qu'on veut que les gens chaque fois ont
provoqué des polémiques mais on la
france ne travaillent pas assez dingue a
pas assez d'heures de jeu met en cause
personne chacun individuellement travail
comme il peut mais quand on fait
l'ensemble du cumul des heures de
travail de notre pays et qu on le divise
par nombre d'habitants sur la quotité de
travail par habitant produit qui nous
permet de vivre d'installer nos régimes
sociaux notre protection sociale fin 2-2
ivre il est très très inférieures à peu
près à tous les autres tous les autres
pays du monde
10 15 20 25 % de moins d'heures
travaillées donc le schéma du travail il
est fondamental si on veut maintenir le
niveau de vie et notre niveau de
solidarité de protection sociale c'est
fondamental
et ça veut dire que ça passe par le
parti des réformes des retraites c'est à
dire partir plus tard du travail ça veut
dire aussi rentrer plus tôt sur le
marché du travail
et ça veut dire quelque chose de
fondamental et qu'on oublie trop souvent
c'est une sorte de de fatalité à
accepter l'idée qu' un chômage de masse
en france c'est autant d'heures de
travail qui ne sont pas pourvus et c'est
un poids comme ça qui pèse de façon très
très lourde et qui handicape notre pays
et qui rend je pense l'ensemble de ceux
qui recherchent du boulou plein emploi
il faut trouver le chemin du plein
emploi le chômage est une est une
question presque
on a l'impression que en france il ya du
chômage c'est comme ça non non c'est pas
comme ça c'est pas possible que la
france grand pays vivent avec 2 3 4 % de
chômeurs de plus que la plupart des
autres des autres pays donc il faut
beaucoup beaucoup d'action d'activité de
réformes dans le domaine de la formation
de la mobilité du travail du droit du
travail de l'assurance chômage la
garantie d'une manière générale quand
emmanuel macron hier en fait par le
dollar et formulations chômage de
révoquer les retraites la relance et ses
îles et demi les aussi dans un discours
de candidat à la présidence de la
république et musher qu'un président de
la république le lendemain de son
élection il est candidat à la présidence
de la république un même poste de maire
fin c'est dans la logique de tout de
tout élu et heureusement j'ai jamais vu
d'ailleurs un chef d'entreprise ne peut
être candidat à sa propre succession
donc on a tous
il faut en de construire dans la région
ce discours mais mais mais mais mais
mais conduit puisqu'il ya tout un
certain nombre de points sur lesquels
nous on a déjà beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé je pense qu'on leur ait fait
on aurait fait des choses avant je pense
qu'on les aurait fait sans doute
différemment à une partie de vote mais
je dois contrôler le jeu
moi je raisonne pas comme ça en jaugeurs
je veux
objectivement je vais pas m'opposer à un
discours qui m'a qui m'a conduit il ya
plein d'autres discours qui m'ont pas
convenu donc le discours allait dans le
bon sens sans doute beaucoup trop trop
tarder ce puis on verra ce que ça donne
je suis pas sûr que la garantie jeunes
est une thune c'est une réforme de coûts
ça veut dire qu'on va payer quoi je je
je je dirais que quand on a un niveau de
dette aussi important quand le président
parler de souveraineté il a raison il
faut parler de souveraineté d'autonomie
de notre de notre pays on peut pas
dépendre des autres qu'il a donné des
exemples mais la dette est une manière
de limiter notre notamment la réforme
des retraites puisque c'est un sujet que
vous connaissez très bien alors il
affirme clairement qu'il faudra
travailler plus qu'il faudra un âge de
départ à la retraite plus tardif
il demande à son gouvernement de
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
dès la rentrée mais dans le même temps
il ne précise pas quand cet enfant ne
sera lancée il dit une fois attendre la
fin de l'épidémie
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
méthode est ce que c'est la bonne pour
vous écouter c'est lui qui a lancé le
sujet comment il aurait pu ne pas le
lancer et l'a lancée maintenant qu'il le
retire
je peux comprendre que le cerveau il le
redira pour l'après présidentielle je
pense pas qu'on y revienne
quand on se rassure change enfin j'en
sais rien j'ai aucune information et
peut-être ne le sait-il pas lui même jeu
à partir du moment où on indexe les
chaussures le sur le sur la paix la paix
médicale sur le fait qu on ait surmonté
cette cette éventuelle nouvelle vague du
duc o ville bon c'est compliqué d'avoir
des mesures qui est qui contraignent les
français mais dans le jeu je pense qu'il
faut le faire et puis en même temps
mettre sur la place publique un débat je
suis bien placé pour le savoir
extraordinairement difficile sur le plan
je le comprends je sais pas très bien je
pense que c'est compliqué aujourd'hui
d'aller dire on augmente l'âge de la
retraite c'est c'est pas compliqué de
dire que tous les français seront moins
1000 euros de retraite à carrière
complète et c'est ça c'est pas très
compliqué de le dire c'est pas compliqué
de dire que le régime de retraite ils
doivent être plus justes faire entre
nous ils sont pas si injuste que ça et
quand il ya 42 caisses comme neil
président enfin ya 80% 85% des français
qui dépendent de trois de trois régimes
quoi donc c'est pas c'est pas trop le
sujet je pense que le sujet c'est à quel
moment on part et avec combien donc à
quai le moment on parle on va partir un
peu plus tard il faut pousser l'âge de
la retraite à 63 64 65 ans un moment
donné dans les années dans les années
qui lui mais il ya urgence cela étant si
on résolvez les problèmes de chômage et
qu'on a à quoi seules à la masse de
travail disponible en france
on aurait évidemment autant de
cotisations qui rentreraient qui nous
permettrait de financer correctement
notre protection sociale
à force de ne jamais vouloir attaquer
les vrais problèmes et bien la france
elle comme ça elle hésite elle elle
bricole pour ils attaquent pas les vrais
problèmes notamment sur cette question
de la dette
il a dit hier qu'il fallait pas laisser
le fardeau de la dette à nos enfants on
les sait déjà le fardeau de dette
écologique il fallait pas laisser les
familles mais ça va être le cas sur
des mots et les actes si on prend pas de
mesure c'est compliqué là on est
toujours dans la halle dans le sanitaire
donc évidemment il faut continuer à
aider les entreprises le plus longtemps
possible
évidemment cela veut dire qu'on prolonge
notre client est un moment donné il faut
l'arrêter mais j'ai comme vous indexé
sur le sur la situation sanitaire
je comprends bien qu'on doit continuer à
lire à la question du chômage partiel
quand des établissements ne pourront pas
faire régner d'une certaine manière l
ordre sanitaire dans dans l'eure dans
leur établissement
le patron le restaurateur et pourra pas
empêcher les gens baisse qui gueule on
sans arrêt mais je peux pas possible et
aussi défaut les passes sanitaires il a
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de faux qui
circulent donc tous à la créer une
ambiance où certains à mon avis des six
rondes de 2,2 de suspendre le reste il
faut donner des signaux très très fort
sur notre capacité et notre volonté à
vouloir maîtriser la dépense publique
parce que la réalité celle ci s'était
d'augmenter la capacité notre pays à
accroître le potentiel de croissance de
notre pays et notre capacité à créer la
richesse doit être plus important et en
même temps il faut maîtriser la dépense
publique mon jeu je remarque aucun
gouvernement n'a réussi à le faire dans
la durée
formation y compris les y compris les
nôtres où les dernières estimations de
l'insee interne ans et 6% de croissance
en 2021 est ce que est ce que ce que
vient d'annoncer président la république
n'est pas de nature à freiner les choses
à votre avis sinon le moral ou sur ce
que vous venez d'évoquer un centre de de
petits patrons qui dirait c'est trop
compliqué je me mets en stand by
essentiellement des restaurateurs de
mais sur le soudan les entreprises je
pense que ça posera aucune aucune
difficulté évidemment chacun s'arrange à
on voit bien que il faut laisser les
gens s'organisent et on est on comprend
bien pourquoi parce que souvent dans le
public et d un responsable qui qui qui
qui qui dit qui dit les choses qui
annonce une réforme personne ne comprend
au fond ce qu'il veut si les pressions
lessive ou qu'il faut à la france et
leur déni on essaye de la guérir et on
guérir à tous ensemble et bien il faut
en passer
évidemment par la vaccination qui est un
geste quand même relativement anodin
entre nous un être vaccinés 6% c'est
réaliste la relance est là pour vous oui
je fasse surréaliste on a fait à moins 9
donc c'est au moins huit donc c'est
évidemment réalise le rebond il est
évident ce qui n'est pas évident les
patrons plutôt le tenir dans la durée le
moral et c'est plutôt au dessus de 2,2
ce qu'on voit d'habitude ce qui est très
important c'est comment on génère le
pourcent supplémentaire de croissance
durablement bas sur un an de revenir à
1,3 ou 1,4 pour cent par don de donner
des chiffres de croissance et ne sait
n'est pas suffisant pour vivre
aujourd'hui dans la france le plan de
relance à 100 milliards et ce qui se
déploie suffisamment vite
ou est-ce qu'on cesse des fois c'est
bien il ya des mesures qu'il faut
supprimer mais il ya une réactivité et
une souplesse supprimer les cahiers non
meublé mesure qui ne trouvent pas de ça
c'est pas que ça sert à rien c'est
qu'elles sont belles montées par exemple
la transformation des dettes en fonds
propres ça veut dire que des entreprises
il faut pour la française manque de
fonds propres elles ont bon elles vont
sortir de cette crise très endettée pour
beaucoup est alors qu'elles devront
investir avec une dette une dette
l'autre donc moi il ya très longtemps
que nous avons proposé est de
transformer au fur et à mesure une
partie de ses dettes en fonds propres
plus plus plus plus disponible pendant
longtemps pour les entreprises je vois
que pour l'instant les le gouvernement a
essayé de faire ça mix end avec ça ne
fonctionne pas alors qu'on est au coeur
quand même d'une dune des solutions
fondamentales pour la stabilité de
l'économie française et pour
l'investissement alors a terminé en
parlant de votre parti oui le la
question chez les républicains c'est aux
primaires pas primaire quel est votre
cas lucho
trop votre parti pris en la matière moi
j'ai toujours pensé qu' il fallait
organiser la primaire c'est à dire avoir
qu'un outil disponible un genre en rayon
parce que si on n'organise pas alors
c'est une fuite en avant
mais il faut tout faire pour ne pas
l'utiliser et tout faire pour ne pas
l'utiliser bas ça dépendra des candidats
et mes candidats allaient l'équipe qui
estime être en mots en droit et d'avoir
la capacité d'être d'être président de
la république
pas une mince affaire d'être président
de la république eh bien ils doivent
montrer cette capacité et au delà même
de leurs présidences de régions où
d'autres ils doivent montrer au fond
cette envie à la fois cette cette
capacité aussi entraîné la france faire
quelque chose de mieux
les français plus je reviens contre pas
son envie xavier bertrand si xavier
montre son nom rue aujourd'hui c'est le
produit
candice et le consultat naturel pour moi
c'est le plus motivé je pense que c'est
celui qui sera retenu une fine et ce je
pense que c'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant il ya d'autres candidats et
ils ont leur propre légitimité
il ya une dynamique s'est créée par les
élections régionales et puis d'autres
qui n'y ont pas participé représente
évidemment quelque chose dans la même
famille politique est évidemment de très
bons candidats on a presque presque trop
mais si cette dynamique permet tel in
fine et de contes de constater qu'un
candidat est mieux placé et va le rester
ce serait mieux que d'avoir des semaines
de débat pour montrer qu'on se rassemble
très concrètement xavier bertrand il
s'imposera naturellement comme comme
comme on l'entend beaucoup à condition
de passer la barre des 20% d'intentions
de sondage dans les sondages
enfin des d'éden 62 vote à la
présidentielle dans les sondages et se
poser comme le candidat la droite qui
pourrait être retenu pour le qualifier
pour le second tour
s'il y arrive il passe sauf qu'il y ait
pas encore assez 20% non enfin on est au
mois de juillet 20 juin
vous dites c'est lui qui sera choisie
mais dont je dis que je suis ce que je
sais pas ce que je pensais qu'il avait
entre gan il commencerait bientôt il a
pris des risques il a été réélu dans une
région sont plus difficiles que d'autres
et bon il y montre qu'il a cette envie
chevillée au corps et que et que et bien
à lui développé après pourquoi il a
cette envie pour quoi faire
comment on feb rendre les français plus
heureux on est heureux
individuellement globalement mais
collectivement on est quand même un
peuple assez pessimiste donc comment on
fait pour essayer d'inverser ce
pessimisme on a de tels talents que mon
dieu utilisez-les ont éclairé la
capacité aussi à réformer cette capacité
à réformer est fondamentale
la plupart des présidents sont élus avec
d'énormes capacités et dans volonté des
dessins sert d'ailleurs de réformes
fondamentales et puis in fine et tout ça
se termine un peu comme ça sans avoir
beaucoup changé les choses donc il faut
absolument que notre futur président ils
soient en capacité de réformer notre
pays et leur papa pour les larmes pas
pour le chant mais ô combien bray plus
heureux pour vivre dans un modèle qui
soit le nôtre un modèle profondément
social profondément juste mais aussi
profondément productif
c'est fondamental est-ce qu'il faut
qu'ils se rapprochent des républicains
xavier bertrand s'y veut être le
candidat sauvé pour moi il n'y qu'un jeu
je fais pas de différence entre xavier
bertrand et l'ère du papier du parti
n'ont aucune différence chez aucune
différence parce qu'il y en a pas ils
sont issus des républicains et jantes
ministre des républicains exavier
bertrand je l'étais moi même aussi été
secrétaire général des républicains
d'abord s'il est sorti ce que les
conditions de l'époque le long t'amener
à le faire mais c'est juste des
conditions conjoncturelles
alors si cette fameuse primaire dont
personne ne veut qu il faut éviter à
tout prix si vous devez en passer par là
c'est quoi le bon timing
vous n'allez pas l'organiser en février
pour des dépôts pour une présidentielle
en avril
non mais peut-être
non je n'en sais rien lui faisait pas
non mais si si faim moi j'aurais pas
gérer ça comme ça enfin vous aurez je
sais pas c'est pas mon nom je tue je dis
pas ça mais je pense qu'on a besoin d'un
candidat assez vite quoi on avait bien
parce que il faut quand il faut quand
même un prix mais je sais bien qu'on
leur montre toujours que ben raween les
candidats il son désir en novembre
décembre janvier
ouais peut-être mais enfin il ya un peu
de crédibilité à mener et puis depuis il
faut installer une candidature il faut
vraiment l'installer on veut pas une
candidature de témoignage je crois donc
on a pas on a plutôt envie d'une
candidature qui passe le deuxième tour
et qui passent le premier tour pour
deuxième tour est en capacité de gagner
bon il faut du temps ils font du temps
pour installer aussi la cohérence de la
droite une candidature ça veut dire une
candidature cordes qui représente
l'ensemble de cette de cette famille on
voit bien que on pense parfois des
choses assez différentes
donc comment on fait pour comment on
fait pour acquérir cette crédibilité on
a su le faire sur le plan local on a des
racines mais on manque de trop et de
feuilles donc il faut un peu de temps
pour pousser à faire pousser tous là et
merci beaucoup merci à rivers d'arrêter
notre invité ce matin stéphane on
regarde la une de ouest france pas
sanitaire vaccination macron durci les
règles à cette à la une de votre journal
merci messieurs
[Musique]